On Saturday, the presidency
of Donald Trump
passed the 100 day mark,
meaning this prank
has officially
gone on for way too long.
(laughter)
With the Donald unable
to get much of his agenda
through Congress,
he's fallen back
on what he does best--
bull(bleep)
about how great he is.
-(laughter)
-He's the best. Just ask him.
In fact, though the next
presidential election is still
three and a half years away,
his 2020 campaign
is spending $1.5 million
to run this ad
touting his accomplishments.
MAN: Donald Trump, sworn in
as president 100 days ago.
America has rarely
seen such success.
A respected Supreme Court
justice confirmed.
Companies investing
in American jobs again.
-(laughter)
-Doesn't that...?
That sounds like the action
news guy voice, doesn't it?
It wasn't the only
newsworthy piece of video
about the 100-day milestone.
In yet another instance
of the most over reported
political story of the year,
ABC went to the Midwest to check
in with working class voters.
If you had to give a grade,
what would it be?
Um, I think
I would give him a B-plus.
-B-plus? And why is that?
-Yeah.
It's just that twittering.
The tweets bother you?
Well, I don't really
read 'em, so...
(laughter)
-(applause) -HARDWICK:
It's only a matter of time
before Trump responds
on Twitter,
"Hey, old bag in a diner
who gives me a B-plus,
-I give your dumb sweater an
'F,' Titanic lady!" -(laughter)
"Yeah, you should have followed
that necklace
"down to the bottom of the
ocean. Oh, I'm still tweeting.
I'm running out
of characters."
Comedians,
what grade would you give
President Trump
on his first 100 days?
Pardis.
Well, they grade restaurants
"A" to "D,"
so I'd have
to give Trump... Chipotle.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
-Ana Marie.
-A.
He is sort of skating by on
Obama's accomplishments anyway.
All right, I'm gonna give you
points on there. Gina.
-Ugh. What's the grade
you'd give dog meat? -(laughter)
Come on. This president has been
nothing but lips and assholes.
-HARDWICK: All right. All right.
Points. -(laughter)